welcome everyone to the night class on a
meal game and I choose this game to show
you it's played by a Viktor Korchnoi he
was considered one of the strongest
players that never became world champion
unfortunately he passed away recently
but two months ago so this game will see
you will see how he played against on a
Tony Karpov and he defeated him in a
great positional style so he was a very
very strong player it's just it was very
unfortunate but it is prime he had to
play with players like Karpov for
example if no Karpov he would be the
champion some players are a little bit
luckier than others to become a world
champion because you know maybe the
competition wasn't as strong or there
wasn't somebody like you know brilliant
like but players were to play with
Karpov Kasparov this was a very very
difficult time because you know they
were basically in the shadow of these
players because they were just
absolutely brilliant so but cautionary
unfortunately he was very close he
played a couple of matches for the World
Championship but couldn't quite win that
last match to become a world champion
see for what is the name of this opening
that Kirchner is trying to play English
very good English is six c-46 but Karpov
says no English he wants to switch this
game to the qgd Queens gambit declined
he says no English by playing this way
he is not allowing the English actually
93 Korchnoi
d5 I've actually played the Viktor
Korchnoi Anatoly Karpov so I've got to
play both of this players I drew against
both of them so we weaker course no I
played about four or five years ago in
Gibraltar and I was black and he was
olders much older but he was still very
very you know playing very aggressive
and attacking chess and he was trying to
press me but hey I was a little bit
worse by I managed to hold the position
so and against Karpov are played in 2007
also very interesting game and the game
ended in a draw d4 so we had different
move order starting with c4 but it
transposed into which opening Queens
gambit declined okay Knight f6 so we
learned a little bit faster in the
opening because today we're going to
focus on middle game man the middle game
at some endgame so take take Bishop g5
this is standard Bishop e7
and now white just simply place
III
castles
dish of d3 do you see now after Bishop
d3 what is why threatening who sees now
what is why threatening what is he
really trying to do here do you see it
yes excellent yes
for example bad move played like this
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen h5
putting pressure putting pressure what
do we call this idea when you're
attacking two things at the same time
double attack or a fork okay double
attack or of work so actually by
visuality you developing a piece and you
setting up a little track blocks is it
course car boss is that Knight f3 Queen
c2 c6
this is one of the main positions of
Queens gambit declined and here Bishop
f6 played by course toy looks like a
strange decision yet why is it doing
that who can explain the decision by car
Korchnoi here to give up his Bishop what
plot is he trying to do here what plan
coach toy is trying to do here yes
excellent excellent thinking very good
so the reason he take because now takes
the place before with idea to play b5
and this is what we call a minority
attack see two paths versus three pawns
minority is attacking the majority one
of the very rare things in chess you see
this happening I am very familiar with
this structure because I having a
default player on my life and I've done
a lot of minority attacks but question
for you what is this structure called
what is this structure called who knows
this structure
very famous you have to go back a little
bit a little bit but it's important that
you know this structure where he has
four pounds versus two and this guy
named calls bud cause bud what did you
say that I didn't hear you actually yes
calls but calls that I think believed
there was a point of any calls button
that's where the things started you know
so this is called everybody make a note
if you want okay that this structure is
called calls above structure you didn't
know this or you forgot
yeah well name is important okay in some
point it's important to know you know
yeah this was like really really popular
like 10-15 years ago a lot of really
popular to set up and of course even
before that they were playing this a lot
so that's what calls about structure
okay Bishop f5 now play Bishop g4 pod on
attacking the night trying to damage the
structure okay
damage the structure costly not going to
let that happen 92 rook c8 it's hard to
imagine white can press here you know
without the bishop but now opponent has
two bishops look what course no does it
get to the one of them to Bishop is an
advantage so immediately he takes away
the light for Bishop no to bishop
advantage for Anatoly Karpov Queen takes
carpo proposed exchange you probably
thought you know why would I be that
much worse see so a four so he continues
with a minority attack here now if you
had to evaluate this position they
should be seven played hitting the pawn
if you had to evaluate this position
here what would you say white is little
better its equal what would you say here
interesting cases Blackie's little bit
there but let me tell you one thing very
important everybody please pay attention
to this blood can only be better if
white plays in accurately somewhere
right because the light starts the game
we cannot be worse so we haven't seen
anything inaccurate right I mean at
least so black cannot be better I think
white has a clear plan which is involved
in put the looks together and b1 c1 and
play b5 clear pun minority attack okay
that is the main idea okay that's why I
put two roots together and you play b5
and the black doesn't really have a very
good point here so he just kind of has
to block it huh rook a b f b1 good
question but let's see how the game
develops then we'll find out a5 i wants
to bet every six ideas he is trying to
provoke you know provoke a black
complain about white playing a six in
Karpov does it carpool Shirley thought
you know how could I lose this position
yes I have one weakness on b7 but I am
so solid no weaknesses
pretty much now Korchnoi brings the
knight in it's amazing that he defeated
core Karpov in his style
this is Karpov style here bishop fa 95
but cracker probably said you know I'm
not going to lose this game I mean yes I
have one weakness but ha normally that's
not enough to win when one weakness so
he has to create a second weakness or
second you know create some more
witnesses on the other hand okay
King f1
so black is going to bring the night to
b6 which is the common way to defend in
this type of positions and he's
centralizing his King again it looks
very very solid for block disposition
okay now I'm going to get to the
interesting moment here rook e1 g6 okay
a lot of top grandmasters at this moment
we're saying black is doing absolutely
fine and even claiming an advantage at
the moment here yeah but some other
people thought white can really create
some things here I think white is a
little bit better still even though
black has very good night here but if
white manages to exchange that night he
will have a slightly better position now
he needs to have a plan okay so I'm
going to give you a little bit of time
here to think to find a plan for white
because you know both players play the
obvious moves for a moment but they need
a plan here white needs a plan if he
wants to try to win this game let's see
if we can find that plan g4 she's
suggesting g4 to grab some space
as I understand correct that idea is
going to be played later but I know he
wants to concentrate on doubling up his
rooks on the e-file and possibly some f3
for breaks so he started with a move
rookie to f6
when we brought this one here he
developed his looks in some point
actually he wants to play before now and
simplify the position so Bishop h6 came
in Karpov is stopping that because you
put before he is going to stop them stop
the night off
Bishop FA back Knight to karpova's happy
with Joe as you can see repeating but
caution is not he played h3 King f7g for
rubbing some space black is just sitting
is a very solid position so he is just
sitting and white is trying to gradually
to improve the position f3 plate he is
getting very close now white realizes he
cannot stop before so he puts the rock
on day to try to create some counter
play on D file 90 b3 Knight d5 again
trying to prevent white from planky for
discourage him basically right the one
fish page six
f4 Knight goes back on D to rook FP 1 he
still wants to play for page six
he didn't rush right away with the e4 so
he played rook F 1 rupee a rook 81
rookie p8 some shuffling here going on
and now what happened was cause I waited
to make a 40th move he didn't want to
make this break under the 48 also it was
very smart he just struggled his pieces
to make the 48 move which you should do
that to a tournament players you should
do that to make the 40th move get
additional time on the clock Oh make
sure you calculate everything and then
go for it a very smart thing he did he
got his extra time he spent probably
another 10 15 minutes here just to make
sure and then he went for it
he wasn't just shuffling for no purpose
he was trying to get that additional
time after moved 40 ok and now he went
for which plum
Eve for yes and now he wants to go he
five carpeau had to take it 98 now it's
very important before black bezel d8 and
puts pressure he need to neutralize this
night okay neutralize the night that's
what he really need to do neutralize it
and how are we going to do that
93 yes rook takes e - Brooke takes equal
Bishop takes c5 BTech c5 rook da Karpov
taki no I have pressure here what could
really happen here course no it took NAB
let's evaluate this endgame what do we
see here
White has White King is in the center
that's a plus right but does he really
have much of an advantage here questions
no yes in the back
Luke 8 who is going to be met by ro k 8
so you're not really gaining that much
there he does have one point that he's
going to do in this position and he's
going to try to get some more space to
fix the position so black is running out
of f5 fixing fixing that King and the
points they can really move anywhere
takes takes now he goes rook g8 trying
to activate his roof now what is the
plum here
now his check is very annoying so what
he's trying to do he's trying to hide
the king on before okay
so King City played rook e8 proposing
the exchange white says no rook t2 and
now looking for
activating his rocket while black play
Rhodesia when here yeah yeah that's
problem there I go here
yeah you could take the pawn but the
problem is I think he just breaks
through and takes everything then break
through and the C pawn is very quick
going down the board c67
you play which move d3 no problem I just
go to yeah
my phone is saying let's break through
let's take it even even here actually
just push it take this one and this this
pawns are very strong because you have
to look at this break you have to look
at that break too strong now he's going
to take on d5 is going to pick up on b5
this pawn is very very slow so advantage
here for question Ellie okay so that's
why he played rooky proposing the
exchange route d2 rookie for trying to
play active King before King GA if black
brings the King over there's not much
going on here so here cautionary goes
for an important break here would you
break I'm referring to here that he went
for you can go deeper this piant a6
Bravo
yes now threating a7 capture is
necessary King a fak in d7 now if you
capture is going to go king c7 you don't
have anything so next move is absolutely
important to play yes king b6 activating
the King to the maximum now if a five
comes in he can even go rook here or d5
break is very strong as well to break
through so he decided to go b4 b5 check
fifty-five check King c8
now this pawn is very quick and annoying
so white play the right thing to start
at first by playing the move rook d3
okay and here Karpov played a five which
was a mistake he was supposed to play
the move rook c4 which offer them the
best chances it looks like he can hold
this position after this move very
difficult but he could play this move
and try to hold a five blue g3 was
played and now panic again panic was
here he should have played rugby for he
played b3 and I think he overlooked a
very powerful move here King c6 King sat
in front of each other tapping
background checkmate now that forces the
King to move thank you for the pawn with
check King a7 another check occurred
check and now this pawn is to be stopped
right axle stopping it and picking up
more pawns here King b5 excellent white
is now completely winning rook takes f4
okay except 6xh 683 check
kake's cleaned up all the palms now
and now root goes back to g3 without
this palm it's a theoretical draw rook
p6 who have six would be theoretical
draw so g3 broke up six check check and
now he wants to push the spine doesn't
want to look here so just put it here
and push the pump and here's the point
resign but I'm not going to resign here
so let's see how you're going to win
this position I will not resign and I
will sit on this
very nice very nice
tic
picking up the room
so we saw a game basically he resigned
here I mean at the Grandmaster level two
pounds is a huge advantage so they don't
have to continue here we saw a very
strong display in this game by
cautionary and this was a world
championship match at the very high
level he managed to play a very very
nice game a couple of things let's go
back to the let's go back to the middle
game here talk about the opening was
Queens can be the high right here they
should have six the first I would say
with unusual decision right because he
is just taking giving up the bishop but
once again now you know why did he do
that you know why this decision was made
to play which plan B for plan which is
called it's called minority attack in a
calls but structure so just remember
that minority attack works in a calls
boss structure we don't really have some
other type of minority attack positions
this is really the only one this con
structure right here a 7 B 7 C 65 versus
a 2 B 2 D 3 this this structure seven
pounds with this yes
uh-huh yes yes if let's say White has a
pawn on c3 black has a pawn on e6 that's
again calls but structure for black and
then black plays which plum minority
attack okay it could happen for example
let me show you
d4 d5 Knight f6 III have the c3 position
and they play the system here kind of
solid call a system take take so you get
your pieces out and then after you
castle you start pushing the spawns and
that's again he's got that same
formation right and you basically play
that same if I before mine usually if
they look b8 and play b5 before that's
how you do the minority attack but in
this this case he decided to actually
take the knight
that's an issue f6 it's not your typical
move here Bishop f6 you normally play it
okay be one ish nowadays most people
play this way but at that time he just
took one f6 again this game was played
nearly oh this game was played very long
time ago in almost 40 years ago 1978 so
it's a so this was a first decision but
again it was based on the minority
attack plan in a call spots structure
and second thing was this move now you
know clearly why he played this move and
what was the reason for victor portion
to do this to get rid of opponents pair
of the bishops when opponent has two
bishops that's considered an advantage
so you want to try to exchange one of
the bishops so you just play Bishop f5
exchange will occur between f5 okay so
you get rid of the bishop so Bishop f5
to X Queen and 5x
and exchange of course and why why white
is better here
the main reason white is better here why
not too much about like he's so much
more active but what's the main reason
he's better huh he has a plan a play a
plan that what he's going to do black is
just basically sitting sitting and
trying to hold yes because if he put the
rooks like this you play b5 you're going
to be met by c5 and then he has a C file
to work with yeah yeah but still c5 is
kind of annoying there see if I was
strong so he actually played this to
play a six here so now a six is going to
be a problem so he kind of forced a six
and then he goes night here c5 okay to
plant that night on c5 and now the good
thing about this position when your
position like this you basically y can
never really be worse in this kind of
structure he can only be better unless
you play really badly here because you
just have positionally you have a nice
position these two guys are just totally
fixing this side of the board and next
thing you just move the king but again
he shuffled yeah for fifteen ones they
shuffled here basically but the plan is
to break through with E for they just
did a lot of shuffling Karpov was trying
to do everything he can to prevent it
but and this next couple of moves they
were just just waiting to make time
control see he just move the rook around
very smart play by corner to make time
control you have several time controls
back in the day they dead adjournment
also that they could return I think this
game was adjourned
in fact so he made a time control then
he sat down he thought about it and then
he went for the break the break that
brought brought him to victory takes 94
if you didn't take care if if he had
done this move here what would have been
the problem why he didn't play this but
what is the typical idea you do when you
play e4 in this kind of positions that
almost always you do this now yes
b5 absolutely if I yes
Night Moves what do you do what do you
do
cement yeah cement the position look it
up look at that passed pawn now but it
goes here now how are you going to break
to here do you see the breakthrough plan
here for white yes let it reach what is
the breakthrough plan correct and then
you just put your looks
double up on the H file okay by the way
you also have a very neat square to go
tool this is a very unusual square but
this is a huge outpost on d7 here that
you can use okay okay excellent so this
was the game of another Viktor Korchnoi
arguably one of the best chess players
who never became world champion because
he had to deal with players like Karpov
which you know he was close you know he
could be bit carpel like he showed here
he did a video many times but he
couldn't just win the match to be the
world champion okay okay I have one
study for you at the end so let's see if
you can try to solve this particular
position okay it's a very very nice
position white to play and win no pants
on the board that means if you don't
check made me or win might win you're
not going to win this game
if you had a pawn white pawn you would
exchange Queens and win easily and
promote a pawn into a queen but here you
don't have that so your choice is either
to come up with some kind of brilliant
mating idea or win his queen
white to play and win it's not about
just checking and checking you know
because a lot of the checking not going
to help so you really want to do it the
right way you know not too much checking
in on here not too much checking no you
have to see the entire thing you have to
look at the best defense also for black
you can just make a bad move and say
check the area that will be easy
everybody would do that ok let's think
let's think you have time I want to give
you as much time as you like here just I
want you to write down down search or
just remember in your head the whole
thing the whole thing yes first of all
you know proudly you see it is the most
natural and obvious move but question is
the follow-up the follow-up is the
question let's put that first move so
you you know where things are this is
checkmate this is a checkmate ok so you
have to go here
it's not a check check check check
solution it's at some point you and I
have to make a very powerful quiet move
to set up that mating net to set up that
net it's a very tricky position there's
a lot of defensive resources okay a lot
of defensive resources here in the
position like pinning and you know I'm
pinning a lot of pinning stuff going on
here
your King is once he starts shaking your
king you can forget about winning this
game because your king is wide open if
his queen somehow checks you then you're
just going to be checked all over the
board strangely enough it's not Queen g7
which is Alan King a5 I escaped neither
fade correct now if it goes here what do
you say checkmate but looks like he's
escaping
no the knight is now not checking me
what are you gonna do the next two moves
are very hard but that's basically the
solution yes ah
Queen is sick psycho King f4 and I'm
escaping so I mean you're gonna give me
a lot of checks after that but no clear
cut to the victory yes
correct answer check now this two
squares are there's a fork so you can I
use this two squares so you're done with
this one but here where it comes the
stunning move I think living
threatening to take your night by the
way if you don't do anything
I'll go ugly take that night this is the
quiet move time remember the quiet move
now it's a quiet move now it's not a
check now hint big hint it's our check
96 I just go back in 5 king is too many
supposed to go to in a wide-open board
you're not going to be able to checkmate
him what are you threatening after Queen
d3 besides that when G 3 I can stop haha
very nice brilliant Queen D 3 now the
threat is 96 mate and that actually
stops the check that black head here
because now you're just going to take it
threatened checkmate here take on take
on taken taken take and everything is
taken so now
he has to take right what else he can do
he can't even go back again night this
and so he has to take it and you had to
see this move you absolutely have to see
the small fish and that is Queen f1
checking in that is the solution that is
your solution okay for this one all
right so this is the original position
if you are interested to write it down
or take a picture of it this is a good
chance for you okay so you can practice
this position at home okay I recommend
you study do more studies okay everybody
should do a little bit more studies to
get a little bit more familiar okay
Kasparian studies are very good okay
this is what I am using the kasparian
studies so that way and try to look
little bit more into that World
Championship match 1978 match between
cautionary and Karpov caution I did
score several wins in that match but at
the end he could not defeat a nepali cup
of to win the title but you can look at
some more interesting and there were a
lot of Jones but I believe drawers were
uncounted so they were just going by the
amount of wins they had his World
Championship match 1978 okay so it was
played in Philippines but your City July
18th to October 18th so they pay for
three months carpet warm the title
retaining the title so let me show you
how it was done I think they had Karpov
had a lead for one course no one game
21st but carpet 127 putting him in a
brick Oh victory pre-code victory with
52 so they were playing six wins the guy
who gets six wins windrows not counted
okay that was the rule God show bravely
fought back scoring three wins and one
draw in the next four games so he had
the momentum yeah
three wins in a draw to equalize the
match and after 35 31
however couple one the very next game
and the match six-five with 21 draws so
they played how many games that is
that's like 32 games yes so they were
taking like some days off obviously but
you could see how close cautionary was I
made sure when he won those games and
5:5 he thought he's gonna finally win
one more win and he is a world champion
yeah so it's he was very close and his
head somehow but this was his closest
because when he won those three in a row
you know he probably felt like this is
my chance
one more win but then purple carpet won
that that that crucial game you know
example I mean we'll go over that but
that shows how close he was you know I
close how close he was you know he beat
all this internals and everything he had
to go to all these qualifiers to win to
get there the you know to challenge so
the system was very interesting I kind
of liked that system but now this is
just not practical to have that many
games played you know nowadays they play
I think I believe it's 12 games yeah
okay so we spend a lot of time
discussing this championship match and
coach know just just introduced to you
this player if you're not very familiar
with him Viktor Korchnoi one of the
strongest players that never won the
title thanks everybody for coming to
this lecture and we'll see you looking
forward seeing your Thursday